with our social fabric gone can we come
back together plus we examine the
fallout from the democratic debate and
talk about the continuing attacks on JK
Rowling I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show the Ben Shapiro show is
brought to you by expressvpn go check
them out right now at expressvpn calm
/ban that's expressvpn calm / Ben
protect your internet activity today
okay well you know what happened I
thought that Friday was gonna be my last
podcast before the vacation it turns out
nope I'm back we're here it's a Monday
and we got a lot to talk about because
some stuff happened over the weekend the
biggest thing that happened over the
weekend before the presidents of the
United States was not the impeachment
stuff because that stuff basically
concluded last week the Democrats
finished their impeachment move and then
they were like you know what not gonna
send it to the Senate not gonna worry
about anymore we're just gonna hold it
back over here you know well McConnell
and Schumer negotiate this thing up so
this is not gonna affect Trump until
next year presumably when they pick up
negotiations again anew in the new year
Senator McConnell has already said you
know don't really carry or in his way
don't really care right in an internal
eternal way but the big news over the
weekend for President Trump of course is
that a magazine called Christianity
today the editor came out and said the
Trump should be removed from office for
the media this was a massive story a
huge unparalleled story because
Christianity today is a very popular
magazine particularly with evangelical
Christians it was founded by Billy
Graham and therefore it has a pretty
good pedigree well Franklin Graham
bilities son but Billy passed away last
year Franklin came out and he said well
you know no he said my father was a
supporter of President Trump's I had no
editorial input on this thing and
historically speaking it is true that
mal get Mark Kelly who is the
editor-in-chief of Christianity today
has been extremely critical of the
presidents in the past in fact just back
in 2017 he wrote an entire piece about
how president from Seoul was in danger
so he has been very much on board with
the president Trump is a very very bad
man and therefore because he's a bad at
moral man he shouldn't be President
train for quite a while
nonetheless the media jumped on this as
though it was something new and this is
indicative about how the media covered
these things the media doesn't know
anything about the evangelical world the
media don't
anything about Christianity they don't
know anything about religious human
beings in fact they are constantly
surprised to learn things about
religious human beings they didn't think
we're possible like that religious human
beings sometimes have doubts about their
own spirituality like that religious
human beings disagree with one another
that religious human beings look at the
Bible and interpret it sometimes and
these are all shocks to members of the
media because none of them actually know
anything about religion well if they
knew anything about Christianity today
they would have actually done like a
Google search of mark alley and they
could have found out that mark alley has
for years been ripping the president up
and down and that galley himself has
been quite anti-trump for quite some
time so that's not actually new the fact
that he came out and he suggested that
Trump should be removed from office that
is not a new thing
and that is that they're treating this
like a Man Bites Dog story - dog bites
man's story - mark galilee bites bites
Trump story realistically speaking now
in one second I want to get into mark
galleys perspective because Mark galleys
perspective is sort of interesting it's
sort of fascinating and it does speak to
a deeper conflict that is happening
within the religious community over the
nature of the United States right now
gonna get to it in just one second first
let's talk for a second about the
quality of your bedding so as you can
tell I'm on the road you know that means
I'm not sleeping as well as I do at home
why well for one thing I don't have the
sheets that make me unbelievably
comfortable I'm talking about ball and
branch sheets everything that Boleyn
branch makes from bedding to blankets is
made from pure 100% organic cotton they
start out super soft they get even
softer over time you buy directly from
them so you're essentially paying
wholesale prices luxury sheets can cost
up to a thousand dollars in the store
bull and branch eats are only a couple
hundred bucks shipping is free you can
try them for 30 nights there's no risk
no reason not to give them a try try
bull and branch sheets today you're
gonna love them how do I know you're
gonna love them because if you don't
like them you can send them back so I
mean like there really is no risk for
three nights you can try them so if it
stinks what you won't you'll send it but
you're not going to in fact they're so
good my family actually throughout all
the rest of our season just got Boleyn
branch to get you started right now my
listeners get 50 bucks off your first
set of sheets at bull and branch calm
promo code Ben go to bull and branch
calm promo code Ben today and get 50
bucks off your first set of sheets
that's bol and branch calm promo code
Benbow and branch calm promo code Ben
okay so here is the editorial that is
making all the rounds from mark galley
and it says Trump should
removed from office quote in our
founding documents Billy Graham explains
that Christianity today will help
evangelical Christians interpret the
news in a manner that reflects their
faith the impeachment of Donald Trump is
a significant event in the story of our
public it requires comment
the typical CT approaches to stay above
the fray and allow Christians with
different political convictions to make
their arguments in the public square to
encourage you all to pursue justice
according to their convictions and treat
their political opposition as charitably
as possible we want CT to be a place
that welcomes Christians from across the
political spectrum and reminds everyone
that politics is not the end in purpose
of our being we take pride in the fact
for instance that politics does not
dominate our home page let's be like a
smart way to do it right they're talking
about eternal values in their
perspective so why exactly would you
then cram down a perspective on
something is hotly fraught as
impeachment that said says Mark Kelly we
do feel unnecessary from time to time to
make our opinions on political matters
clear always as Graham encouraged us
doing so with both conviction and love
we love and pray for our president as we
love and pray for leaders as well as
ordinary citizens on both sides of the
political aisle let's grant this to the
president the Democrats have had it out
for him from day one and therefore
nearly everything they do is under a
cloud of partisan suspicion
again this is Christianity Today's much
ballyhooed editorial this has led many
to suspect not only motives but facts in
these recent impeachment hearings and no
mr. Trump did not have a serious
opportunity to offer his side of the
story in the house hearings on
impeachment but the facts in this
instance are unambiguous the President
of the United States attempted to use
his political power to coerce a foreign
leader to harass and discredit one of
the president's political opponents that
is not only a violation of the
Constitution more importantly it is
profoundly immoral okay first of all
whether that is true or not is actually
at issue right the question that I've
been asking for a long time is was this
about 2020 or was this about 2016 was
this about harassing and Joe Biden with
an eye toward 2020 or was this president
Trump looking back at 2016 being
irritated that he's been accused of
cheating in the election by working with
the Russians being whispered in his ear
by Rudy Giuliani that Ukraine was really
behind some of the election manipulation
looking at stories in Politico in the
New York Times about how the Ukrainian
embassy was coordinating with members of
the DNC to dig up dirt on Paul manna for
hearing other rumors from Rudy Giuliani
about other corruption going on in
Ukraine and so Trump irritated by the
Mullen report being told by Rudy
Giuliani that the 20s
sixteen election cycle was really about
Ukraine not about Russia he decides that
he's gonna go forward with this quid pro
quo attempt it's not about 2020 in other
words about 2016 so the question was
always what is Trump's intent here
Trump's intent was never proved because
only one witness who actually had an
actual human conversation with Donald
Trump Gordon Sunland testified and he
didn't bring the goods this is the
problem for the Democrats cases why not
a single Republican has peeled off but
according to our galley the facts are
not in dispute okay but that's really
not the crux of this piece the crux of
this piece is that he thinks that
President Trump is an immoral man and
this is where we're gonna get to a
deeper question in America right now and
that is do we have a social fabric such
that it is possible for us to cast
someone out of office for immorality
alone do we have a social fabric where
it's possible to even evaluate our
candidates on a character level anymore
well that's that question in just one
second the editorial continue says the
reason many are not shocked about this
is that the president has dumbed down
the idea of morality in his
administration he has hired and fired a
number of people who are now convicted
criminals he himself has admitted to
immoral actions in business and his
relationship with women about what she
remains proud okay all of that stuff is
is prior to his presidency obviously and
this mirrors a lot of the things I
believe about the president I don't
think the president is a sterling
character when it comes to his business
or his women you'd have to be I think
blinding yourself to reality to think
that his Twitter feed alone says Mark
Kelly with his habitual string of
mischaracterizations lies and slanders
is in your perfect example of a human
being who is morally lost and confused
Trump's evangelical supporters have
pointed to his Supreme Court nominees
his defense of religious liberty and his
stewardship of the economy among other
things has achievements that justify
their support of the president we
believe the impeachment hearings have
made it absolutely clear in a way the
Malheur investigation did not that
President Trump has abused his authority
for personal gain and betrayed his
constitutional oath the impeachment
hearings have illuminated the
president's moral deficiencies for all
to see this damages the institution of
the presidency damages the reputation of
our country damages the spirit and
future of our people and then he equates
this with the call for impeachment of
President Clinton he says the
president's failure to tell the truth
even when cornered rips at the fabric of
the nation this is not a private affair
for above all social intercourse is
built on a presumption of trust trust
that the milk your grocer sells you as
wholesome and pure this what they were
about
Clinton trust that the money you put in
the bank can be taken out of the bank
trust that your babysitter firefighters
clergy and ambulance drivers will all do
their best and while politicians are
notorious for breaking campaign promises
well in office they have a fundamental
obligation to uphold our trust in them
and to live by the law say unfortunately
the words that we applied to mr. Clinton
20 years ago apply almost perfectly to
our current president whether mr. Trump
should be removed from office by the
Senate or by popular vote next election
that is a matter of Prudential judgments
that he should be removed we believe is
not a matter of partisan loyalties but
loyalty to the creator of the Ten
Commandments so many evangelicals who
continue to support Trump in spite of
his blackened moral record we might say
remember who you are and whom you serve
consider how your justification of mr.
Trump influences your witness so your
Lord and Savior consider what an
unbelieving world will say if you
continue to brush off mr. Trump's
immoral words and behavior in the cause
of political expediency if we don't
reverse course now says Mark Kelly will
anyone take anything we say about
justice and righteousness with any
seriousness for decades to come can we
say with a straight face that abortion
is a great evil that cannot be tolerated
and with the same straight face say that
the bent and broken character of our
nation's leader doesn't really matter in
the end we have reserved judgment on
Trump for years now some criticized us
for our reserve when it comes to
condemning the behavior of another
patient charity must come first so we've
done our best to give you the angelical
Trump supporters that are due to try and
understand their point of view to see
the Prudential nature of so many
political decisions they have made
regarding mr. Trump so use an old cliche
it's time to call a spade a spade to say
that no matter how many hands we win in
this political poker game we are playing
with a stacked deck of gross immorality
and ethical incompetence and what just
when we think it's time to pull all our
chips to the center of the table that's
when the whole game will come crashing
down and crash down on the reputation of
evangelical religion and on the world's
understanding of the gospel it will come
crashing down on the nation of men and
women whose wealth honor is also our
concern okay so that's the that's the
much-ballyhooed editorial as I say it's
not new so it's weird for the media to
treat it as news but it's an argument
that ought to be confronted by
evangelicals and also it should be
confronted by religious people of every
stripe and by Republicans who look at
Trump's character and say yeah Trump is
a man who has always had serious real
and abiding character problems you know
that really doesn't have to do with
impeachment and here's sort of the point
if you are going to link impeachment and
Mark Kelly basically says this race is
whether it's impeachment or whether it's
the next election we
Trump out but that now becomes a
political question not just a moral
question and this is what I'm gonna
explain in a second in order for it to
be true that the chief question in
election is the moral character of our
leaders we have to have a broad social
fabric agreement on values across the
board I'll explain that in just one
second first let's talk about protecting
your data and the fact is that The Daily
wire invests tons of resources into
cybersecurity like a lot because when
like there are lots of people out there
trying to hack us we have to protect our
security we have to protect our data you
as an individual also be doing the same
thing because the fact is you don't need
tons of hackers trying to hack you in
order to make your life miserable all
you need is one cuz if you're
unprotected they take that credit card
number and then you just run that out
there on the dark web and next thing you
know they've stolen your identity or
they steal your data and then they
militarized it against you they use it
in some way orbik tech grabs it and then
they use it and they monetize it without
your permission this is why you ought to
have expressvpn you might be thinking
security threats don't affect you this
is wrong all they have to do is get you
once that's it you have to be right
every time they only have to be right
once this is why you should be using
Express VPN and then they can't even
hack you once so when are you going to
get expressvpn and do it now visit my
special link right now expressvpn comm
slash man get an extra three months of
expressvpn for free protect your
internet today with the VPN I trust to
keep my data safe go to expressvpn comm
slash band to get started that's expr
ESS VPN comm slash been to get started
expressvpn comm slash been ok so a lot
of the logic in this piece is logic that
honestly I felt back in 2016
really I felt the President Trump back
in 2016 was not of moral character to be
President of the United States and so I
didn't vote for him and I didn't vote
for Hillary Clinton it is also true it
is also true than when it comes to the
allegation that everyone who voted for
Trump was somehow selling themselves out
morally that was something I just didn't
agree with I didn't believe that was
true I thought that the Prudential
consideration those being made by many
Republicans was short-sighted and in
some ways I was wrong and in some ways
I'm not sure if I was wrong right we'll
have to see ten years from now history
will be the judge and we'll find out ten
years from now how this plays out he's
been much more conservative than I
thought he would be
he has justified his statements on
religious freedom on abortion on a wide
variety of issues that I care deeply
about as
not only religious human being but is
just a conservative generally but when
it comes to the the implication that is
being drawn by this editorial that's
something I never did in 2016 election I
never said to people if you vote for
Trump it makes you a bad human being or
a bad Christian the implication of this
editorial is that if you vote for Trump
or if you think he shouldn't be
impeached it's because you have decided
to make Trump into an idol and if you
watch Mark galleys Twitter feed after
this that's basically all the things
he's been tweeting out he's been
tweeting out a variety of emails from
people who have fallen into a sort of
idolatry for Trump there was one thing
he tweeted out somebody texted him or
emailed him and said what do i Jesus
isn't coming back anytime soon who need
Trump is our protector and he was like
well now you're substituting Trump for
Jesus that's not cool well if I were
questioned I'd feel the same way
obviously as a Jew I feel the same way
Trump cannot become God to you Trump is
a human being with all of his attendant
flaws and with all of his attendant
qualities yeah there's good there's bad
that's who Trump is but to substitute
Trump for your faith is of course a
large mistake however in order to make
the claim that you are undermining your
own faith they are undermining your own
morality by opposing Trump's impeachment
even assume it let's assume for a second
galleys case which has yet to be proved
that Trump did something super terrible
here and then it's worthy of impeachment
even assuming that is the case on a
pragmatic level can a moral human being
say you know what we don't live in an
America anymore
where I trust the other side to abide by
rules because I think that that is
really what's going on here I think that
in the best of all possible worlds most
evangelical Christians and most
Americans and most religious people
across America would say to themselves
that when a president sins we would
rather that person not be president but
we also recognize we don't live in that
ideal world we live in a very flawed
real world where political priorities
are connected to candidates and where
the solid ground that we thought we were
standing on the aftermath of in the
aftermath of Richard Nixon leaving
office this solid ground where there are
some lines you just don't cross and if
you cross those lines then we're gonna
stand up and say no way that died during
the Clinton impeachment it did died
because it turned out that half the
country was willing to say yes he
committed open perjury yes the man was a
derelict yes the man lied under oath yes
he committed
action of justice but we don't care
because he's gonna give us abortion and
so a bunch of people on the right said
okay well then we don't share the social
fabric anymore see in order for you to
believe that moral people are betraying
the social fabric by not throwing a
president out of office for immorality
you have to believe that there is a
social fabric that is there in the first
place
in other words we all have to be living
in the same sphere right we all have to
be living on the same moral plane we
have to at least have a certain level of
baseline if the baseline is not there
then there's no nook right I mean then
you are operating without a net and then
it just becomes okay well the Democrats
are gonna take over they're never going
to impeach president no matter what he
does that president is going to come in
and mandate abortion basically is going
to come in and it is going to suggest
that you have to pay for other people's
abortions and as a religious human being
you're an evangelical Christian you save
yourself okay so here is the balance now
the balance is not between a moral moral
United States and a less moral United
States the balance now is between
policies that are going to preserve
lives with the unborn and policies that
are not because the moral United States
is gone okay and this is the great
tragedy of what's happened in the United
States over the last 30 40 years there's
a mainstream belief right left and
center that the moral basis of the
United States is not here anymore
there is no social fabric we share where
we think that certain activity is
off-limits and certain activity is still
within limits we don't think that
anymore and evangelical Christians are
coming along now with Trump and they're
saying okay he's a recognition of
something we didn't want to recognize
he's a recognition that I mean even
listen I know tons of evangelicals they
were very very split of mine even though
they go to overwhelmingly for Trump
they're very split of mine about Trump
himself and now here's where Gally's
observation makes sense okay if Gally's
observation is that people who fall into
idolatry are betraying religion that of
course is true and if his observation is
that it's very bad for religious people
to make excuses for trumps bad behavior
that's true too I've been saying that
all along
every time Trump's something does
something that's bad something that's
immoral does something that's wrong it
is up tomorrow people to say that is bad
that is wrong that is no good but when
it comes to the Prudential consideration
of who ought to be leading policymaking
we can no longer operate under the
assumption that we all agree that
immoral people should not be present we
don't all agree on that Bill Clinton was
president okay we don't agree on that
and we haven't agreed on that for quite
some time and the right acknowledging
that and saying okay well I guess if the
choice is between playing by Marcus of
Queensbury rules while have a crotch
punch oz on the moral issue and then
implement policy that actually harms our
religious freedom then I guess we'll
have to acknowledge a reality that we
wish we didn't have to acknowledge which
is that we don't live in a country of
shared morality anymore and here's how
you know this is true if there are an
evangelical pastor in a community and
that evangelical pastor committed
adultery that evangelical pastor
presumably be out of a job tomorrow why
why it doesn't matter how much charity
he raises doesn't matter how much he has
done to build the church doesn't matter
how many people he is converted if an
evangelical pastor commits adultery and
that comes out in the church he's out
the reason is because the constituents
all share the same moral fabric it's
certainly true in my religious community
right and if the rabbi does something
wrong the rabbi's out why because we all
share the same moral fabric and this is
true in our local community right if
you're in a local community with a lot
of people who share your same moral
sentiments if somebody does something
morally wrong even if you like their
politics you say okay well we all share
we all share enough that the risk of us
getting rid of this guy isn't the
complete demise of all of our priorities
and also we at least get to uphold a
certain moral level but when we don't
share anything when we don't share
politics when we don't share morality
then every political battle becomes a
life-or-death battle where morality of
the politician takes a backseat now
again your own morality is still on the
line when it comes to how you
characterize that politician this is
where the editorial is right right it is
it does not behoove any evangelical any
religious person and religious Jew
anybody in the United States to cover
for bad acts by a politician you know be
upfront about the fact they are gonna
vote for Trump even though you think
that the guy is horrible with women
that's true
he is horrible with what I'm not gonna
lie about that I'm also gonna recommend
that if we're going to elect somebody
that the top priority be that that
person implements policies that are not
going to continue to undercut not only
the social fabric but things that are
that are endemic to our rights things
like religious freedom things like
freedom of speech now all the pillars of
our civilization are crumbling away
right now and some of those central
pillars are the rights that are
protected by the Bill of Rights if
somebody is a moral person and the left
proclaims
moral but we know the left doesn't care
about morality because the left was fine
with Bill Clinton right if the left says
well here's our moral candidate who's
gonna chip away at all the Foundation's
they haven't restored any moral fabric
there's a lack of basic trust and the
lack of basic trust continues on a day
to day land and you can see how the
editor of Christianity today is actually
running right past Trump it's really
it's quite fascinating it's an
interesting intellectual exercise so
here is Mark alley the the editor of
Christianity today saying that when
Christians support an immoral cause it
does damage to my cause well that's true
but you have to define immoral cause is
the amoral cause you're supporting Trump
being an adulterous Lech with with
stormy Daniels if that's the moral cause
then I agree
if the immoral cause is I'm gonna vote
for a politician who is going to
preserve the right to religious freedom
and the right to life and I'm going to
freely acknowledge that the man has is
is horrible on a variety of character
scores but also then I don't trust a
Democrat to uphold those basic rights
and so I'm not going to do this thing
okay that's not immoral so here's the
Christianity today editor who's
conflating the two and I guess again I
think the reason he's conflating the two
is because there are so many people who
do make the mistake of conflating the
president's character with his
accomplishments there are a lot of
people out there who do this routine
where it's like I love these judges I
love what he's doing I love the man the
man's great hey you can love the man you
can love what he's doing you can love
all these things but you got to
acknowledge the man's sins if you're a
religious person and you hope to obtain
any any solid objective sense of
morality here's Mark galley as a
Christian I like to think of myself as a
person who has given my ultimate loyalty
to Jesus Christ and the gospel he's
called us to proclaim so when Christians
of any stripe support a cause that
strikes me as manifestly immoral it does
damage to the cause that I've given my
life to so I think that's one part of
the equation that all Christians
especially my brothers and sisters new
evangelical world need to think about
more seriously and more deeply okay and
then President Trump immediately fires
back on Twitter and you can see they're
talking right past one another right
past what is fascinating right Trump
fires back and he says I guess the
magazine Christianity today is looking
for Elizabeth Bert Warren Bernie Sanders
or those of socialist/communist bent to
guard their
how about sleepy Joe the fact is no
president has ever done what I have done
for evangelicals or religion itself so
you can see in Trump's tweet how he's
missing galle and you can see from from
street why galle is saying what he's
saying right from trump's tweet you see
he's missing galle because he's not
saying listen i'm gonna try to be a
better moral person i am a moral person
i'm trying to do my best I'm struggling
with it instead it's look how much I've
done and this is how a lot of un tronco
voters are looking at Trump right he is
a vessel for policy priorities because
there is no social fabric anymore and
you just need a guy on the wall and if
that guy is Trump that's the guy who's
on the wall okay and then the very end
is why galley
can't stand Trump right the very end
where he says no president has ever done
what I have done for religion itself
right galleys like what hold up a second
now now you're getting into my territory
because the fact is that the president
when it comes to upholding religion and
the cultural value of religion having a
president who actively stands for moral
values is actually a pretty important
thing so you can see Trump is talking
right past gali gali is talking right
past Trump and all of that is because of
the tragic occurrence that our social
fabric is worn we don't trust each other
with morality we don't have a shared
social institution like a church we
don't it's not I recommend them Jew it's
not a recommendation of top-down
religion we do not have shared social
institutions where we share values
anymore and in the absence of values
politics becomes everything politics
becomes absolutely everything that's
what's going on and that's why you're
seeing this divide so you can have
sympathy for Galli and what he's saying
morally and at the same time recognize
the what he's saying about other
Christians is actually wrong on the
merits and just a second I'm gonna talk
about why it is that we feel like there
is no social fabric because it's pretty
obvious we feel like there is no social
fabric first let's talk about the fact
that life insurance is probably on your
to-do list so life insurance I know you
don't want to think about it we're
getting near the end of the year you're
thinking oh do I really want it's a
great time of the year think about your
own death think about your own mortality
like oh no yeah but you got to get it
done so go to policy genius calm they
don't have to think about it anymore
policy genius makes the super easy
policy genius makes finding the right
life insurance a breeze in minutes you
can compare quotes from the top insurers
to find your best price you could say
fifteen hundred bucks or more a year by
using policy genius to compare life
insurance policies once you apply the
policy genius team will handle all the
paperwork and the red tape
and policy genius doesn't just make life
insurance easy that can also help you
find the right home and auto insurance
disability insurance this holiday season
do something for your family do
something for your loved ones go check
out policy genius calm right now get all
the insurance coverage you will ever
need
go to your their life insurance right
now a policy genius calm competitive
shopping saves you money and time it
only takes a few minutes to find the
right life insurance policy apply cross
another thing off your to-do list policy
genius when it comes to life insurance
it is indeed nice to get a right policy
genius calm go check them out right now
that's policy genius.com okay so you can
see why people are coming apart at the
seams
why are evangelical christians
supporting Trump because they look at
the culture and they see people who are
being featured in the culture like
Robert DeNiro for example prominent
people in the culture and they say to
themselves these are the people I'm
supposed to trust with morality I'm
gonna be lectured by Robert DeNiro and
the moral compass of our leader I'm be
lectured by people who are for abortion
on demand all the way up till birth on
the morality of the leader of the free
world because it seems to me that I can
criticize trumps morality being a moral
human being in my own right but people
in Hollywood they don't have any right
to do this
DeNiro says there has not been one thing
about this person that has been
redeeming as far as I can see he say he
said shame on them and then he said that
he would like to see a bad quote I'd
like to see a bag of bleep right in his
face bleep being feces hit him right in
the face like that and let the picture
I'll go all over the world
he needs to be humiliated he needs to be
confronted and humiliated by whoever his
opponent is they have to stand up to him
they don't have to do it in an obvious
physical way but they have to have the
form and ability to confront him and put
him in his place because the people have
to see that to see him be humiliated
hey religious people understand that
Robert De Niro isn't talking just about
Trump there Robert De Niro is talking
about any religious Christian anybody
who disagrees with him on politics
anybody who disagrees with him on
abortion Robert De Niro is not just
talking about his personal dislike for
Trump in fact were it not for the fact
that Trump is a Republican Robert De
Niro would be having dinner with Donald
Trump Donald Trump was featured on the
Emmy Awards Donald Trump had a huge show
on national TV he was hanging out with
all these people Hillary and Bill
Clinton were at his wedding the same
people who want to hit him with a bag of
bleep right in the face today are the
same people who five seconds ago
hobnobbing with him why not because
they're so upset over his moral
qualities it's been obvious for 50 years
of Donald Trump's life what his moral
qualities are it's specifically because
they're upset with his politics this is
the lie this is where things this is
where the untruth is obvious and Mark
galley says the people are looking at
evangelical Christians and say look at
those hypocrites because they support
Donald Trump do you think any of those
people had great love for evangelical
Christians when they were supporting
Mitt Romney great love for evangelical
george w bush I don't I I mean I've no
religious person I don't remember
secular people loving me anymore when I
was at when I was supporting George W
Bush or John McCain or Mitt Romney I
remember that at all neither does
anybody else religious in America we
were getting crapped on day in and day
out for years when Trump says they're
attacking me because they're attacking
you that's true they're not attacking
him for all the reasons they say they're
attacking him you think anyone in
Hollywood gives two damns about Donald
Trump's sex life these people will stop
anything that walks four legs two legs a
centipede it does not matter these are
people who live the most dissolute
lifestyles that you could possibly
imagine and then and then you really
believe that they're sitting there like
prudish Calvinists being like oh well
you know Donald Trump and his personal
moral standards this is where I draw the
line know the reason they hate Trump is
because Trump represents a bunch of
people they hate even more than they
hate Trump by the way if Donald Trump
were a deeply moral person they'd hate
him even more than they do they would if
Donald Trump were it because you know I
can tell you this Mike Pence right Mike
Pence end of story
they're castigate they crapped all over
Mike Pence for saying that he won't go
to dinner with a woman not his wife so
don't give me that's all about Donald
Trump's moral character or that they're
gonna look at evangelicals like they are
hypocrites okay the only reason they
would look at evangelicals like they're
hypocrites if evangelicals looked the
other way on Trump doing this stuff
right that's legit right if a if a
religious person says Trump's adultery
bad for you good for him No
bad for everybody okay but if you're
gonna pretend that you're appealing to
people by ripping on Trump by ripping on
Trump some moral character
okay you're not appealing to these
people
like I promise you that the only time
Christianity today has ever received a
kind word in the press ever the only
time Billy Graham has received a kind
word in the press ever is when they came
out against Trump it's the only time
ever I promise you you will not find a
single New York Times article going back
as long as this magazine has been around
praising Christianity today for their
moral stance ever so what does this
really about it's about they don't like
Trump and they don't want Trump in
office that's why he's receiving the
strange new respect they don't respect
you they only respect you when they
think they can make hay out of you that
is all that is happening here and
religious people understand that and
that is why religious people are
fighting back against all of this this
is why there's an article in The New
York Times over the weekend called fear
and loyalty how Donald Trump took over
the Republican party the president
demands complete fealty and as the
impeachment hearings showed he has
largely attained it to cross him is to
risk a future in GOP politics okay
that's true I think there's a lot of
truth to that I think that if you are a
politician and you criticize Trump I
think that that could be a serious
problem for you but I think it's also in
how you criticize Trump meaning if you
criticize Trump and say look dude it's
terrible with women one of the problems
here is that Trump because he is so
vindictive he can't just let stuff like
that go he has to try and defend himself
from stuff it's obviously true and so he
says things that are that to target
members of his own party which is which
is foolishness but beyond that I think
that that people see attacks because
people rightly see attacks on Trump very
often as attacks on them they've started
to see any attacks on Trump as attacks
on them and that's a mistake that is a
mistake if you start to see any attack
on Trump as an attack on you you got to
consider the source
you got to insider' the nature of the
attack is it coming from a place of love
or is it coming from a place of you want
to see him fall cuz you hate his
priorities or you got actually analyze
all of that but again the divisions in
the country are so deep right now and so
abiding that people don't trust each
other like look we know we're not gonna
get credit hey let's be real about this
if the Republicans got rid of Donald
Trump tomorrow let's say the Republicans
in the Senate turned around in tomorrow
they're like you know what you're right
impeached then they got rid of Trump and
Mike Pence were president do you think
the Democrats will turn around and say
look at those moral decent beautifully
ethical Republicans and now they're
running this beautifully
the cool man Mike Pence and they've
really turned a corner you know I'm
voting Republican tomorrow anyone think
that anyone because if you do you hit
your head on a rock that's not the way
this works anymore we are past that
maybe back in 1973 people thought that
and maybe that was more accurate back in
1973 when Richard Nixon was resigning
it ain't accurate now yeah I've been
accurate for 30 years in this country
been quite a while okay in just a second
we're gonna get to one instance of this
sort of divide and why it matters but
first let's talk about the number of
gifts you are gonna be receiving this
holiday season people love you they love
your kids they're gonna be sending you
all sorts of gifts Oh what does that
mean it means FedEx guys come into your
house like all the time and when FedEx
guy shows up he's gonna ring that
doorbell there's another one problem
what if FedEx guy is Appert is not FedEx
guy what if he rings the doorbell you're
not home and he's doing that just to hop
your fence so you can rob your house a
lot of people who are attempting to
break and enter will actually ring the
doorbell first to make sure you're not
home and then they'll go into your house
what do you need to protect yourself you
need ring-ring helps you stay connected
to your home from anywhere so if there's
a package delivery or a surprise visitor
you get an alert and you're able to see
here and speak to them all from your
phone if you're on the go this season
whether it's across town or across the
country you can check in anytime for
some much-needed holiday peace of mind
my wife and I were obviously worried
about security and for good reason we
get a lot of threats so we have written
security devices all over our property
we are constantly ensuring that we are
safe and secured by using ring as a
listener you have a special holiday
offer on the Ring welcome get available
right now with a ring video doorbell
two-inch I'm pro the ring welcome kit
has everything you need to keep an eye
on home no matter what this holiday
season brings with ring you are always
at home just go to ring comm /ban that
is ring comm /ban additional terms may
apply okay speaking of stories that
demonstrate our massive political divide
the Army has now investigated those
cadets remember there are these cadets
they were on ESPN's game day and they
were giving the okay sign remember this
is like a week ago
we're in the okay sign and all of these
morons in the media were like that's
white power white power signs those
white supremacists secretly infiltrating
West Point secretly infiltrating the
army and they were taking it Navy taking
over the halls of power and everybody
else is like they're playing the circle
game circle game is where you hold this
this okay symbol below your waist if
somebody votes you punch
the shoulder so the army did a full
investigation of this a full
investigation here is what they found
summary the evidence strongly supports a
finding that names of these people made
okay hand gestures during the ESPN
broadcast of game day because they were
playing at the circle game or gotcha
game there is no evidence that they hold
any racist or white supremacist views or
attempted to communicate such messages
by using the okay hand gesture on
national television no evidence at all
so all you morons in the media ran with
this is it covered by the New York Times
by CNN Malcom Nance on MSNBC was like
this is a serious issue requiring full
investigation or alternatively you're
suspicious of your fellow Americans for
rationales that do not exist the social
fabric is frayed beyond recognition at
this point seriously seriously frayed so
what can bring people back together
there's a real question what can bring
people back together well a mutual
agreement on morality would be a good
start but it has to be mutual and it has
to be open it can't be just a
generalized sense you have to feel like
the other side isn't cheating and so
that means we need to see some evidence
on the part of the left I think we've
seen some evidence on the part of the
right from time to time I think Roy
Moore not winning in Alabama is pretty
good evidence if there are a bunch of
people in Alabama who are not willing to
vote for somebody if their crime is so
significant that it even overwhelms the
politics of the situation and if
Democrats run somebody who purports to
be moderate and moral all right that's
what happened with D with the Doug Jones
election in in Alabama have you seen
anything remotely like that on the
Democratic side of the aisle when was
the last time the Democrat said you know
what this person is too immoral to be in
office when was the last time they said
that they could say maybe Katie Hill or
is that congresswoman from California
maybe so maybe that's the start of
something you know could be hopeful at
the end of the year maybe that's the
start of something somehow I think that
it had more to do with the political
inconvenience of Katie Hill being in
office for Nancy Pelosi than it had to
do with morality let's see them do that
in electoral situation not in a
situation where that gap is gonna get
filled by a Democrat automatically when
there's actual risk attached then then
let's see them do that but we're gonna
need a consistent pattern of behavior
from both sides of the aisle where they
say repeatedly that immoral behavior on
their own side as well even if it
doesn't mean that they vote against the
person to get rid of them like I'd love
to see Democrats actually suggest that
ohan Omar is
an anti-semite because she is or
Rasheeda Talib I'd love to see Democrats
come out in real time when a Democrat
does something that is wrong or immoral
and say that that's wrong or immoral as
opposed to circling the wagons because
it's gonna need both sides letting down
their guard just a little bit to
reestablish this level of trust and it's
going to need less online interaction
because online interaction social media
interaction is inevitably the worst sort
of interaction this the people you see
at church you agree with them because
you see them at church the people you
see in your bowling league or the PTA
meeting they're people you can deal with
on a personal level because you see them
on a personal level we need to rebuild
trust away from social media social
media actually exacerbates the problem
it does not make the problem better in
two it's a better way of separating
people than connecting them atomizing
people as opposed to showing them what
exactly they have in common it's the
reason why we just had a great year
economically and people are still at
each other's throats
it's a pretty good demonstration of the
of the lack of truth to the nominee
Marxist Nostrum by the way the material
circumstance dictates the health of a
body politic that obviously is not true
we had a great year economically and
politically we're about as fragmented as
it is possible to be okay in just a
second we are going to get to the
democratic debate and the fallout from
the democratic debate kind of a surprise
winner here I'll get to that in one
second first this is the time of year
when you are starting to figure out okay
you know what I'm gonna eat up do what I
want during Christmas during Hanukkah
and then after the new year I am getting
fit I'm getting healthy now I know
you're gonna make that pledge to
yourself but here's the thing you're not
gonna change your habits you're gonna
get a gym membership it's can go unused
for three months you're gonna let it
wane as you probably should if you're
not using it instead you need to
actually change the way you live the
best way to do this is with the new map
based in psychology Noom teaches you why
you do the things you do arms with the
tools to break the bad habits and
replace them with better ones I've been
using Noom for several months here and
it gives you tips every single day it
helps you chart calories it helps you
come up with a regimen that works for
you NUMA isn't a diet it's a healthy
easy to stick to way of life it works
great alongside other diet programs by
the way no food is good bad or
off-limits noon teaches moderation can
be used in conjunction with many
pre-existing popular diets we're all
strapped for time noon just asks you to
commit 10 minutes a day for yourself
I've been using new myself as I say for
months it is really effective it's great
it reminds me every day
to stay healthy you don't have to change
it all in one day small steps make big
progress sign up for your trial today at
noon calm / Shapiro that's oom calm / a
Pierrot what do you have to lose visit
new mom / - Pierrot start your trial
today that's Noom calm / Shapiro the
last weight loss program you're going to
need okay so fall out from that big
democratic debate
so 5:38 has done a little bit of polling
they did a in a 538 it shows poll is
conducted using obsesses knowledge panel
and an interview the same group of
voters twice once on either side of the
debate to capture both the before and
the after picture and it's kind of
fascinating to see who went up and who
went down and who didn't do great
so everybody apparently went up which is
not surprising because it's a showcase
for everybody it's a showcase for
everybody in just one second by the way
we are going to continue with all of
this we're going to explain exactly what
happened with this with this entire
debate fall out first great news game we
have the perfect gift for you to give
this holiday season the gift of a daily
wear membership from now until January
1st all insider plus gift memberships
will be 25% off unbelievable this means
your loved one will get all the
fantastic perks plus the majestic
leftist here's tumbler you will receive
the savings again 25% off all insider
plus gift memberships this holiday
season if you already have left his
tears tumbler you are clinking it with
me in unity but if you do not you're
missing out and you could be you could
be participating in this joy if only you
get a membership right now give them the
gift they will thank you for all your
long go to daily wire.com slash gift to
get your 25% off again that is daily
wire.com slash gift and get your 25% off
do not wait
[Music]
okay so now let's get to that 538 Pole
so this 538 pole shows some movement the
movement the biggest moon is in favor of
a meek lava char which makes perfect
sense she's the one who face-planted
people who to judge Buddha judge had
himself a pretty terrible night what
this poll showed is that before and
after the May this share of respondents
who are considering voting for each
candidate before the debate 52% for
Biden after the debate 54% for Biden so
an increase of a little bit under two
points Bernie Sanders an increase of
about one point five points Elizabeth
Warren saw an increase of 0.8 so bad
debate for Elizabeth Warren as I
suggested Peabody Judge saw an increase
of just point eight again a Bad's made
for people to judge as I suggested Amy
Klobuchar saw an increase of five point
two points in the number of people who
are interested in her so that's a big
jump for her Andrew yang saw an increase
of 0.9 so not much for him and Tom Styer
saw an increased about 1.4 points
according to the 538 project the biggest
winner in terms of attracting potential
voters was clearly Club achar who gained
a little over four points in the share
of respondents who said they were
considering voting for her Biden and
Sanders also gained nearly two points
into each and potential support no one
seems to have lost any potential
supporters although candidates like yang
Warren and Buddha judge made only small
gains of less than one point each
candidates favorable and unfavorable
ratings among likely voters basically
basically unchanged except for Buddha
judge Buddha judge saw a significant
move in the direction of unfavorability
he saw a little bit of movement in
favorability too so people have stronger
opinions of Buddha judge than they did
before the debate so 21 percent of
voters see Buddha judge unfavorably
before the debate it was about 17
percent so about a four point move for
Buddha judge in the wrong direction
Elizabeth Warren is exactly where she
was Bernie Sanders is basically exactly
where he was Tom Styer is a little bit
more unfavorable but also a lot more
favorable so people have stronger
opinions on him Klobuchar had a big move
in terms of favorability a seven-point
move in terms of favorability yang had a
big move in terms of favorability so
it's exactly what you would think it is
so bottom line is that yang in Klobuchar
I saw the largest jumps in net Fame
ability six point three points for yang
six point one for Klobuchar most of the
other candidates made modest gains of
two or three points Buddha judged his
net favorability actually fell by about
two points before the debate by the way
about 36 percent of Democrats said that
sharing a stance on the issue is the
most important thing as opposed to 64
percent who said ability to be Trump was
the big thing and that is why you saw
Buddha judge take the head because
Klobuchar was the first person to point
out that Buddha judge has no credentials
to actually win this thing here is Amy
Klobuchar on explaining yeah I was
waiting I was waiting to hit booty judge
over all of this this is the debate and
I think it was done in an appropriate
way I actually been waiting to do that
since the MSNBC debate the month before
where we went back and forth some about
that issue and then he had made that
statement oh you know there was a
hundred years of experience on this
stage and what has it given us
unfortunately it been went to Tulsi and
I never had a chance to reply well this
time I did now that doesn't mean that
the Buddha judge doesn't have his
defenders as I suggested Buddha judges
response to the wine cave stuff was
basically correct he said that Elizabeth
Warren was putting forth the purity test
that she herself could not hold by the
corporate charters smack of Buddha judge
definitely resonated because it's true
the guy who owned like eight thousand
votes in South Bend Indiana and when you
ran statewide he got his butt kicked I
mean just got destroyed but there are
some of the I do I do love watching all
of the populist in the Democratic Party
who yell and scream about rich people
talk about how they love wine caves they
love wine kids now Gavin Newsom of the
governor of California he defended
Peabody judges wine cave event he says
he shouldn't apologize for success that
games been used by Democrats
probably probably 100 hundred
congressional representatives have
benefited from the use of that soap are
you kidding I'm in the business so I
know that place well
[Music]
what is it about where Democrats are
good at grudging I don't know okay but
here's the thing like that's what
Democrats do they do apologize for it
success like that's that's that's their
thing it is it is hilarious to watch
Democrats proclaim that their poverty is
actually a great qualifier for office in
no other area of life would you ever
believe this right if somebody came to
marry one of your children and they were
like I'm poor you'd be like that's not a
great qualifier like it may not be
disqualifying but it felt like the best
qualifier if somebody showed up and they
ran they ran a business and they showed
up to do your business they said by the
way I have like no clients
why would I use you right I want at
least somebody with some Yelp reviews
yeah Buddha judge who has no Yelp
reviews The Oprah views he does have her
mediocre and also like he is not a
person who has proved himself in the
business world at all so being not
wealthy from South Bend Indiana winning
eight thousand votes is not a strong
pitch so that that is hilarious by the
way Michael Bloomberg this is worth
noting so people have been saying that
Peabody judge is moving the party back
to the center and Klobuchar is moving
the party back to the center well if you
really thought that the party was moving
back to the center of the Democratic
Party they wouldn't be saying things
like this Michael Bloomberg who's a
supposed centrist he came out he said
he'd vote for Elizabeth Warren over
Donald Trump which is patently insane
this is a candidate who's just saying
she wants to put rules on capitalism if
this man is that dangerous why would
people sooner vote for him I can only
tell you if I were faced with Elizabeth
Warren or Donald Trump I would vote for
Elizabeth Warren even though I don't
agree with her on a lot of things she is
honest and smart and hard-working
so there you are the Democratic Party
still in search of a candidate Biden
continues to be the most durable guy out
there in all likelihood at this point
you got to say he is the odds-on
favorites to take the nomination but man
those debates
wow-wow gonna be a lot of malarkey a lot
of a lot of talk about age thing will be
sponsored by Metamucil it's gonna it's
gonna be an entertaining year guys
really entertaining here okay quick
update so the media continued to go nuts
on JK Rowling JK Rowling of course
committed the gray
an unforgivable sin of defending a woman
who had suggested that men cannot become
women
that men cannot change into women I know
it's unbelievable that somebody would
even contend that a man cannot magically
become a woman
but JK Rowling said it and she is
getting ripped up and down
Charlotte climber who is a transgender
woman in US Army veteran which is to say
a man who believes that he is a woman
his press secretary at the Human Rights
Campaign which tweets out idiotic things
like trans women are women trans men are
men non gender binary people are non
gender binary you know nonsensical crap
that used to land you in the cuckoo
house because anybody claiming that a
man is one or a woman is a man like ten
years ago you'd be like what now say hmm
okay now this is not only established
belief you can rip down one of most
popular authors of all time based on her
saying that women exist according to
Charlotte climber in the magical world
of Harry Potter the justice minded and
rebellious adolescent characters drink
something called Polyjuice potion to
temporarily take on the general
appearance of other people even those of
entirely different anatomies and gender
expressions as a teenager I remember
reading this in thinking oh god I wish
it were that easy right but that because
that like one is like fiction in like a
magical world where wizards happen just
to note that that's not reality at the
time I was very much in the closet as a
transgender girl with scarcely any
vocabulary not even then familiar eyes
familiar medicalizing term gender
dysphoria to explain to the adults in my
life how I was in pain and the world JK
Rowling offered created escape it wasn't
the genre elements that appealed to me
but the central message of courage in
the face of the evil and authenticity in
the midst of urged conformity woven
throughout the narrative is an
insistence on love and community and
integrity and inclusion which is why it
has broken my heart in recent years to
see Rowling's inexplicable replacement
of justice minded imagination with
bigotry driven rejection of science and
reality okay you know delusional you
have to believe to be to believe that it
is bigotry driven rejection of science
and reality to say that women exist
it's bigotry driven rejection of science
and reality and women don't exist I mean
that is like yeah that is the hyper
essence of sexism to suggest that I a
man can be a woman is patently sexist
but to to then suggest that it is
rejection of science and reality
to say that a man cannot become a woman
okay we are living in cloud cuckoo-land
now on Thursday Rowling tweeted a
defense of the British research from aya
forest at ur whose employer does
declined to renew her contract in light
of forest at his own tweets which
included statements such as men cannot
change into women for aesthetic her
former employer to court or the judge
sided with the employer in her tweet
rallying effectively dismisses the judge
suggesting that forest enter was being
fired for stating that sex is real a
common transphobic assertion that has
been dismissed by medical experts and
other scientists that sex is real has
other scientists really oh really I'm
gonna ask you for like a biology
textbook that says that sex doesn't
exist so used to be the argument was
that gender is completely distinct from
sex right sex exists but gender is
distinct from it and gender is a social
construct so all of the things that make
women seem female like femininity that
stuff is actually just a social
construct but female anatomy is female
anatomy and there are women but those
women don't have to be feminine because
gender is a social contract that was the
old feminist crap okay and it was not
true in the first place because gender
is innately connected with biology in a
wide variety of ways but then it becomes
gender is a social construct but sex is
real now it's gender is real and sex is
a social construct do you see the
reversal their gender these gendered
characteristics for transgender people
they're the real reality but your sex is
fake it doesn't exist okay I'm gonna
have to I'm gonna need an explanation
from Charlotte climber how people create
other people through sexual reproduction
I'm gonna need the explanation without
sexual dimorphism I'm gonna need some
explanation on this one
you know without like the small gamete
side of species with the big gamete side
of species I'm gonna need some
biological explanation on this one but
apparently JK Rowling is very very bad
and very very transphobic for being anti
scientific for saying women exist as a
man says it right a biological man says
that so he he would know but he is a she
because because he believes that he is a
she obviously and that's from science
actually that is science so exciting
exciting stuff happening okay time for a
quick thing that I like and then a quick
thing that I hate so quick things that I
like Britain has finally advanced
it's brexit bill in a lopsided vote
according to the New York Times after
more than three years of anguish
national debate multiple cliff-hanging
votes in two general elections Britain's
Parliament voted by a wide margin on
Friday to advance Prime Minister Boris
Johnson's brexit plan paving the way for
a country to leave the EU next month for
all the drama of the moment the vote
3:54 to 234 was a foregone conclusion
after the landslide victory of mr.
Johnson and his Conservative Party last
week the outcome was never in doubt with
Parliament now firmly under the grip of
conservatives the days of fierce debate
over Britain's future which had thwarted
Johnson and his predecessor Theresa May
are gone the House of Commons has become
an efficient vehicle to enact brexit I
love the New York Times coverage listen
to the sentence the House of Commons so
recently a grand arena for Democratic
defiance has become an efficient vehicle
to enact brexit so in other words when
people that the times like are
obstructing brexit that's just
democratic defiance man but when people
who run the government right because
they were elected do what they were
elected to do then that is an efficient
vehicle brutality by the way if Labour
were in charge and they're ramming
through anything
the New York Times be look at look at
the efficiency there that's efficiency
so before it was just obstruction from
the Conservatives that's it that's how
all of this nonsense works the House of
Lords has to give it to imprimatur it is
unlikely to obstruct the bill that was
enshrined in the manifesto of the
Conservative Party
so Bret said is finally going to happen
as it should the people of the UK voted
for it in the most populous referendum
in the history of the UK so good that's
about time and it is a blow against the
international institution that is the EU
which had overstepped its boundaries
with regard to regulations in a way that
the British people did not like so good
for the people of Great Britain okay
time for a quick thing that I hate
[Music]
so I'll admit that I have not yet seen
rise of Skywalker I look forward to
seeing rise of Skywalker I've heard
mixed reviews but people I trust
actually say it's kind of good so I'm
looking forward to giving you my review
of it twitter has a moment twitter
moments twitter such a dumb place filled
with dumb things here is a dumb thing
from Twitter to end your year they have
a Twitter moment looking at rise of
Skywalker's depiction of gender race and
sexuality it's a science fiction movie
about aliens who fight in space with
people but the people are not from Earth
so it's a galaxy far far away and we're
gonna have a conversation about lesbians
in space
thanks Twitter I'm glad we could do this
I'm also old enough to remember when
Star Wars was considered a movie for all
ages including children as opposed to a
social justice warrior vehicle for
various political identity groups but
absolute silliness some had an issue
with Ray's relationship with conflicted
villain kylo Ren and they quote an
article from some random website called
SW shadow Council Star Wars shadow
council saying that the rise of
Skywalker glorifies abuse and assault
against women I haven't seen it yet I'm
gonna go no on that okay I'm just gonna
go out to limb and say I don't think
that that's what the movie does I'm
fairly certain that's not what the movie
does and then they continue they say the
movie's treatment of its non-white
characters has had both praise and
criticism how about did you like it some
are seeing the minor role given to Asian
American actor kelly marie tran as part
of the problem no that no it's cuz roses
a crap character i'm sorry she was a
terrible character it's not because she
was Asian look at how are you talking
about like don't make a crappy character
Asian and then we're fine with like the
person who's in the movie like what
worked what okay like a lot of people
had problem with Finn they think that
Finn's a boring character you know who
wasn't a boring character Lando Lando is
awesome you know they have in common
they're both black this is so stupid
everybody's like oh well you know stud
and and I love when people like Star
Wars what a sexist what a sexist film
Princess Leia is the driving force
behind the original Star Wars films
Padme is a major force in the in the
second wave of the Star Wars films so
ridiculous the
the fact that we have to do this every
time a big-name movie comes out the
franchise's first onscreen kiss between
a same-sex couple has also sparked both
positive and negative reactions
apparently there's like a very very
brief kiss between two women in the
background of a celebration of some sort
and it's it's a historic first because
if the movie doesn't at least throw some
sort of South to GLAAD then the movie
has not fulfilled its basic mandate that
homosexuality exists in galaxies far far
away like okay fine what what ever
whatever it's also boring it's also
irritating it's also stupid it's these
sorts of culture wars where people are
like you know what baguette we got
nothing in common Trump I mean that
really that's what's going on okay so I
hope that you have a wonderful Christmas
this time for real is like our actual
last podcast of the year so I hope you
have a wonderful Christmas I hope you
have a Happy Hanukkah if that's what you
celebrate I hope that you have a
wonderful new year and we'll see you
back here next year for 2022 an election
year we'll see you then i'm ben shapiro
this is the ben shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Rebecca Dodd poets directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey supervising
producers Mathis Glover and Robert
Stirling technical producer Austin
Stephens associate producer Colton Haas
assistant director Pablo white house key
edited by Adam Tsai events audio is
mixed by Mike Romina hair and makeup is
by Jess well alvera production assistant
Nick Sheehan the ben shapiro show is a
daily wired production copyright daily
wire 20 19 hey everybody its Andrew
Clavin host of the Andrew Clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the American Republic is
collapsing the end of days is
approaching and the moon has turned to
blood but on the Andrew Clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the Andrew Clavin
show and laugh your way through the
apocalypse with me Andrew Clayton
[Music]